-Let's see what else we do.
-Make mac n cheese.
-Cook the--.
-The Paris recipe.
-Okay, okay. Cool.
-I'll grab it.
I know exactly
what to do then.
How to make
easy cheesy mac n cheese.
Your friends will love
this crowd pleaser.
Mine always do.
Well, that's that.
Oh, wow.
-This.
-Mozzarella.
So, you do it
with everything?
Oh, wow.
She's like...
-That. Forgot how to do it.
-Okay, so...
One, boil water. Two, drain.
And all that.
This is the recipe
for Paris.
This is Paris's
recipe, guys.
Yeah.
Mine is basically like that
with all of this.
Like throw it on.
I know we had
to put hot water, right?
Well, yeah.
Wow!
-So that, and then salt.
-Want me to put--
No.
Why is this salt glittery?
It's glittery salt.
Every little detail
is like perfect.
The salt is diamonds.
That's how I roll.
How are we going
with the butter?
It's great. It's just...
Fucking up your nails?
I never wear nails.
Going to need
a little bit more
-and then we're good.
-So, what's next?
One half quar--
one quarter. Is it this?
Yeah, look.
Look at that little thingy.
-Oh, it's tiny.
-So it has to be that.
-Why is it so tiny?
-Don't know. Don't get it.
It makes no sense.
Should we just change it?
-Probably. One... that.
-There. Yeah.
-Let's do that.
-I like milk.
And then,
what else did we do?
-We have to put cheese. No?
-Yes.
-Everything?
-Everything.
This, that, this.
-Gonna put all of this?
-Yeah.
Wow.
All of it?
Yeah.
There's like
15 types of cheeses.
Cheeses is bomb.
Okay. Like this.
What do you usually have
for Christmas?
It depends.
I'm in Puerto Rico
every Christmas.
So, the pork.
They literally kill it
in my house. Yeah.
-A pig?
-Like a pig.
-Aw.
-I know.
I had a pig named
named Princess Piggelette.
Like,
I'll never eat pig again
because I'm obsessed
with her.
It depends what you want.
Like, I don't want the pig.
So random.
So, my grandma just does
for me the tortellini.
Oh wait, so what time is it?
Oh, shit.
Oh my God.
You were literally...
-Right on time.
-...on time!
-Okay.
-You're psychic.
Careful, that's hot.
Literally.
Yo, okay,
I think this is ready now.
All right.
Yass!
And then you put that,
I think, right?
It's stuck.
Open it.
Open the vagina.
Uno, dos, tres...
Wow! We made it.
Yes.
To be honest,
I didn't have faith.
Well,
we always had to have faith.
You could do anything.
Oh my God, it's so bomb.
It's actually really
fricking good.
Sick.
-Okay.
-Wow.
Oh my God, it's so cheesy.
It's so cheesy! I love it.
This is the best
mac n cheese in life.
-Gonna grab something...
-What?
It's just boring
how it looks.
It needs to be hot.
This... is cute.
Chanel.
Look at that.
It looks like a cake.
It really does.
And like, Gucci.
This is sick.
-That's how you do it.
-Wow.
Macaroni and cheese.